6 heures du matin le jour se lève sur la
place elliptique à le lieu de rendez
vous quotidien de tous les équatoriens à
la recherche d'un travail au black
depuis trois ans une sévère crise
économique
étreint espagne à madrid les 500000
émigrés équatoriens la prennent de plein
fouet
ici les règles ont changé avant le
travail au noir était réservé aux sans
papiers aujourd'hui ils sont des
centaines de travailleurs légaux à
espérer un job de quelques heures ou de
quelques jours
maintenant ça fonctionne de la même
façon que le marché noir
les patrons ne veulent pas donner un
contrat de travail mais ici la plupart
des personnes ont des papiers
kléber est arrivé en espagne en 1996 le
pays alors en plein boom économique
comptable en équateur il devient
topographe à madrid pendant 13 ans avant
de se faire licencier en 2009 le début
d'une longue traversée du désert
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai un vrai sentiment de
douleur parce que je me sens impuissant
début 2000 en équateur la machine à
billets nourrit une inflation de près de
100 % par an pour sauver sa tête le
président jamil mahuad annonce alors la
dollarisation de l'économie
la première en amérique latine pour les
classes moyennes le résultat est
catastrophique
le pouvoir d'achat s'effondre et l'exil
devient la solution la terre promise est
vite choisi même langue âge d'or
économique direction le pays de l'ancien
colon l'espagne à madrid autour de la
place le manager bien rodé les
pistoleros les chefs de chantier
viennent en voiture chercher de la main
d'oeuvre équatorienne bon marché le
tarif 20 euros par jour et hop une
cotisation sociale
[Musique]
elle était en vie
m
triste constat beaucoup de volontaires
et peu d'élus à madrid les autorités
préfèrent fermer les yeux selon les
équatoriens un véritable braquage légal
fin de journée sur par là un quartier
prend les terres du sud de madrid
aujourd'hui kléber était serrurier il a
travaillé 12 heures pendant le faste des
années 2000 l'état développe une
politique soutenue de facilitation
d'accès à la propriété
kléber s'achète un appartement puis
vient le temps du chômage et des dettes
depuis un an qu'il ne peut plus
rembourser la saisie de son logement est
imminente ce soir il a rendez vous avec
ivan un ami économiste venu pour le
conseiller
[Musique]
je me cherchais le document que m'a
envoyé le tribunal pour me réclamer
l'argent ok
chambre
perdu dans la jungle administrative des
dizaines de milliers d'équatoriens comme
kleber se sont fait escroquer par les
banques espagnoles ils ont souscrit sans
le savoir des crédits à taux variable
avec un contrat facile à signer les
impossible à lire
comment tu peux lire ça
c'est illisible anglais
je ne sais pas comment je vais faire
pour le lire et comprendre ce qui est
marqué et encore nous on parle espagnol
on peut comprendre ce qui est écrit le
problème c'est qu'on ait ni juriste ni
avocat
avant je payais 930 euros par mois
puis il y a deux ans est monté à 1200
euros
et aujourd'hui je paye 1499 euros par
mois c'est vraiment impossible
mais ce qui effraie kléber c'est la
double peine une loi espagnole qui
oblige les personnes à rembourser la
totalité de leurs crédits même après la
saisie du logement
un peu de lumière
c'est ça la réalité que je vis ici
quand j'aurai trouvé une solution je
voudrais rentrer chez moi le plus vite
possible
boehner est certainement c'est ça ma
réalité
à madrid celle qui aident les sinistrés
équatorien victime de la crise
immobilière et des arnaques bancaire
s'est elle aida qui nato à une indienne
quechua de 45 ans le visage façonné par
le soleil le vent et le froid des
montagnes andines aïda est employée de
maison à madrid elle gagne 700 euros par
mois
bonjour je voudrais un petit fromage
il ya du maïs par là j'aimerais bien
voir du bon maïs
et ça c'est vraiment une petite douceur
pour faire face à la crise aida à la
solution une économie parallèle importé
d'équateur
dans un monde réel comme ici il faut
acheter ça c'est la réalité mais dans un
monde idéal la solution serait
d'utiliser le troc on essaie de le faire
ici petit à petit le troc c'est une
façon de lutter contre la crise en
espagne le chômage atteint actuellement
20% de la population 30% chez les
immigrés
[Musique]
quartier de sainte bias l'un des plus
pauvres de la banlieue madrilène
aujourd'hui aïda rendez vous avec des
amis de l'association conadi dont elle
est présidente
ensemble ils espèrent trouver une
solution au problème des hypothèques
poubelles dont est victime entre autres
la communauté équatorienne
il faut qu'on continue à voir comment on
s'organise tout ce qui a été demandé
tout ce qui a été fait et tout ce qui
peut être fait tout ce qui a été fait
dans les médias est partout et là on
pourra établir nos revendications
ici c'est un peu le bureau des pleurs
tous ont lourdement surendettés c'est le
cas de mercy et de son crédit de 230000
euros
c'est pas possible de vivre comme ça on
ne peut pas s'acheter de meubles
l'hypothèque on ne peut pas manger mieux
on ne peut pas aller au ciné il faut qu
on ne peut pas sortir dîner parce qu'il
faut payer l'hypothèque on est des
esclaves de l'hypothèque
il nous paye un salaire pour ne pas
qu'on meurt parce qu'ils ont besoin de
nous pour les enrichir ça c'est une
nouvelle forme d'esclavagé
une maison ou un appartement saisie et
en plus un crédit sur 20 30 et parfois
50 ans à rembourser les banques
espagnoles se servent deux fois sur le
dos des équatoriens littéralement
étranglée par un système aberrant au
sein de la communauté le ras-le-bol est
immense beaucoup rêvent de rentrer au
pays un retour illusoire conditionné par
l'acquittement de leur dette
au sud de madrid quelques terrains de
fortune le rayon de soleil des
équatoriens dans un quotidien difficile
c'est les coins molly un volley ball
médine equateur
je sèche le terrain
les quoi boli c'est le sport national
avec le football un filet et trois
joueurs par équipe un sport qui ne coûte
rien
[Musique]
chaque week-end en équateur on joue à
l'éco aboli
a juste besoin de deux poteaux un filet
dessiner les limites du terrain une
balle
et c'est bon
ici pas un terrain deco abolissant
vendeurs ambulants au menu boissons et
plats typiques du pays
il vous reste deux mois le tsunami oui
mon reste bien chaud c'est à moi
c'était ça un gobelet je ne t'aime pas
le canon scié
[Rires]
c'est bien pour oublier les problèmes du
quotidien
la crise pour oublier un peu la crise
pour se distraire c'est l'objectif de
tout ça et 16 autres étaient modestes
aujourd'hui kléber espère un compromis
avec son créancier la saisie de son
logement mais pas le remboursement de
son prêt échelonné sur 35 ans peu de
chances d'y parvenir le droit espagnol
est aujourd'hui du côté des banques